Long ago, an astrologer looked up, and glimpsed
the primeval current in the sky above.
Then, miraculously, what they saw in the cosmos
actually manifested in reality - and the very
amber of the stars rained down on the Lands
Between.
This glintstone of the cosmos would go on
to inspire those that studied it - but there
was also a darkness up there, between the
stars.
And what some saw, would break their minds..and
inspire a fate worse than death.
This is the story of Elden Ring's Cosmic Sorcery.
A force that would define an entire era of
life, in the Lands Between
---
It all began with the "Founding Rain of Stars",
a legendary sorcery that was the "founding
glintstone sorcery" [Source: Founding Rain
of Stars].
You might have missed this spell in your playthrough
- but it's located here, hidden along an illusory
path leading to the Heretical Rise, within
the Mountaintops of the Giants.
Its description reveals that it is "the eldest
primeval sorcery, said to have been discovered
by an ancient astrologer".
Now..we don't know who this astrologer was.
But we know he was not alone.
For it was here, in these icy peaks closest
to the sky, that the "Astrologers, who preceded
the sorcerers, established themselves" [Source:
Sword of Night and Flame].
And with ancient tools of astronomy, they
looked to the cosmos above, and read fate
in the stars [Source: Astrologer's Robe].
But this was more than mere stargazing - the
stars quite literally govern fates in Elden
Ring.
We learn this from the Starlight Shards and
Amber Starlight items.
The former is a pale blue shard - what remains
of a passing flash of starlight [Source: Starlight
Shard], and the latter is the same, except
with a pale amber glow, and it tells of the
belief that "if the stars command our fates,
then amber-hued stars must command the fates
of the gods".
During Seluvis's questline, the blue starlight
shards are distilled into a blue tonic, which
can be given to other NPCs to turn them into
summonable puppets.
You are..quite literally using starlight to
forcibly control and take away their fates,
when you do this.
These same "intoxicating draughts" had historically
been used in the Eternal City [Source: Starlight
Shard], as is exemplified by the Nightmaiden
& Swordstress Puppets, who chose this controlled
fate for themselves, presumably to better
serve the needs of the Eternal City.
You can learn more about that in this video,
where we discuss the Eternal City in its entirety.
But the Nox of the Eternal City weren't the
only ones that drew power from the stars.
The Royal House of Caria too, drew great power
from Astrology.
The Telescope specifically is a small part
of a larger "astrological tool" that was "used
by members of the Carian Royal Family", for
their own brand of "Carian astrology" that
revolved around Rennala, and the Full Moon.
But to most, the moon was not considered equal
to the stars - and it was the stars that most
would draw upon for their sorcery.
These sorcerers would come together at Raya
Lucaria, a place of learning, that institutionalised
the practice of glintstone sorcery.
And this is our little triumvirate of three
factions.
The Nox, the Carians, and the sorcerers of
Raya Lucaria - who all trace their origins
back to astrology.
They overlap at times, they interact, and
clash, and their shared history is fascinating..and
complicated - but it all comes back to the
stars, in the end.
---
But let's return once again to the "Founding
Rain of Stars", which tells us that "the glimpse
of the primeval current that the (ancient)
astrologer saw became a reality, and the stars'
amber rained down on this land".
[Source: JP Founding Rain of Stars].
But: what exactly is the primeval current?
Well, let's break down the term.
The word "current" means it's a moving "flow"
, or a "torrent" [Source: Comet Azur], and
the word "primeval" means that this "torrential
flow" likely existed from the very beginning
of time.
And thanks to the description for Comet Azur,
we know that the primeval current is a "distant
starry expanse", something that is visually
similar to the torrential comet generated
from this spell.
But what's truly amazing about this cosmic
force, is that, somehow, this ancient astrologer
managed to manifest a rain of stars upon the
earth, merely after glimpsing it in the primeval
current of the cosmos, far away.
And I speculate that Starlight Shards are
actually another example of this phenomenon.
Their description reveals that these are "what
remains of a passing flash of starlight" [Source:
Starlight Shard], and we exclusively loot
these at the foot of giant stone astrolabes,
which are these ancient stargazing tools [The
exception being the Cathedral of Manus Celes,
which is itself built on a famous stargazing
field].
Thus, rather than being a piece of a star
that has fallen to the ground, I think these
might be a byproduct of the act of looking
up at the stars.
Why else would we loot them here?
And so, in that same manner first established
with Starlight Shards and the Founding Rain
of Stars, Glintstone Sorcerers would go on
to replicate this phenomenon - using their
powers of comprehension [Note: Intelligence
is "comprehension power" in JP] to conceive
of new cosmic elements that could be manifested
in reality.
Or, put another way, they formulated "spells"
that let them throw giant rocks at eachother,
and it was a huge hit with everyone.
But among these glintstone sorcerers were
some, who wished to truly understand the mysteries
of the primeval current - no matter the cost.
These were sorcerers like Lusat and Azur,
who would literally become crystal in order
to sync up with and better understand these
powers of the cosmos.
And then there was Sellen - the graven witch,
who threw all ethics to the wind, and wished
to see humanity ascend - no matter the cost.
For the stars..are alive.
Look at Astel, for example - a malformed star,
but a star nonetheless - birthed from a void,
or so it is said [Source: Remembrance of the
Naturalborn, Bastard's Stars].
But I'm getting ahead of myself.
Most sorcerers, however, would be content
with merely manifesting cosmic power.
And so, they would embed physical glintstone
into a staff, and using it as a sort of catalyst
for the stars above[Source: Astrologer's Staff,
Staff of Loss].
You need such staffs to channel spells in
Elden Ring, and Sorcerers needed glintstone
to study - thus,, having access to physical
glintstone was likely quite an important thing.
And luckily for the sorcerers, Glintstone,
being sourced from comets and meteors, had
fallen to the Lands Between before.
So these valuable crystals were mined, and
put to great use.
So, atop and amidst enormous quantities of
glintstone in the Lakes of Liurnia, a place
of learning was built.
An institution, known as the Raya Lucaria
Academy
---
Sorcerers, as a whole.. were powerful.
They could read fate in the stars, fire cosmic
projectiles at their enemies, and potentially
even command the fates of others.
So naturally, there needed to be an institution
for their power.
A place of learning, but also a place of heirarchy,
and even governance, where rules about sorcery
could be debated, and enforced.
When you journeyed through Raya Lucaria, you
would have collected symbols of such a thing.
These are stone masks, called "Glintstone
Crowns".
And not just anyone is supposed to wear these
crowns.
They're a symbol of achievement, and they
represent one's mastery of a certain conspectus,
or school of learning, within the academy.
[Source: Swift Glintstone Shard, Glintstone
Crowns].
They also make a good weapon, if all else
fails.
But why was this design specifically chosen
as a symbol of achievement?
Well, according to many item descriptions
- there isn't just life in stone - but there
is wisdom contained therein, as well.
So, their masks were crafted of stone, and
set with glintstone.
The glintstone is typically set upon the eyes,
and/or the brain, a tradition that I speculate
originated with the sorcerer Azur, who was
one of the first, if not the first glintstone
sorcerer.
His blue-green glintstone crown [Source: Azur's
Glintstone Crown] was set with crystals, and
eventually replaced his own brain and skull
altogether, which enhanced his powers by helping
him catalyse with glintstone - though it clearly
came at great physical cost.
[NOTE: This is reflected in the gameplay,
as all glintstone crowns increase the power
of your sorceries, at the cost of another
attribute]
And I specify that his crown eventually replaced
his own brain and skull, because glintstone
does that.
It corrodes.
It consumes.
We see its effects best on other creatures,
like the dragon Smarag, who was a devourer
of sorcerers, with a body that become corroded
over time by glintstones, thanks to his strict
sorcerer diet.
But, as with Azur..this corrosion did not
come without benefits, and he now breathes
a powerful glintstone breath.
The sorcerer Azur was an early sorcerer of
the primeval current.
But he wasn't the only one.
There was also the sorcerer Lusat, who experienced
a similar glintstone convergence of body and
mind.
Together, these masters of sorcery each glimpsed
a part of the primeval current.
And from what I gather, the primeval current
seems like the sort of thing that can only
be glimpsed once, before it either breaks
or terrifies the viewer.
Azur and Lusat only have one primeval current
spell each, after all.
For instance, "When Lusat glimpsed into the
primeval current, he conceived of the spell
"Stars of Ruin", and beheld the final moments
of a great star cluster, and upon seeing it,
he too was broken" [Source: Stars of Ruin].
And "when Azur glimpsed into the primeval
current, he saw darkness.
He glimpsed beyond the wisdom of stone [Source:
Azur's Glintstone Staff], and conceived of
the spell "Comet Azur", but was left both
bewitched and fearful of the abyss".
Both Azur and Lusat clearly had a prominent
role at the Academy, but Azur specifically
was the first founding glintstone sorcerer
to have an impact upon Raya Lucaria.
For there is a line of research, called the
Karolos Conspectus, dubbed "The oldest of
the academy's lineages of study, begat by
the sorcerer Azur" [Source: Karolos Glintstone
Crown].
Scholars who follow in his footsteps by studying
this conspectus pursue the mysteries of comets,
leading to new kinds of comet sorceries like
Glintstone Cometshard, and Shard Spiral [Source:
Shard Spiral, Comet, Glintstone Cometshard].
Each conspectus appears to be named after
a founding individual.
These stone crowns are designed after actual
people, after all - people you can see in
the flesh, upon their matching portraits in
the academy.
So even though the Karolos Conspectus follow
the path began by the sorcerer Azur [Source:
Karolos Glintstone Crown] - their conspectus
of learning must have been formalised by someone
named Karolos.
But as time went on, more conspectus's needed
to be created, as new lines of inquiry were
discovered.
And so logically, the Olivinus Conspectus
should have been the second to be created.
For this line of research is also concerned
with the study of meteors in the primeval
current, except this conspectus "began with
the sorcerer Lusat".
Their spells study clusters of stars, with
lesser spells like Glintstone Stars and Star
Shower all echoing the great Stars of Ruin
spell that originally broke Master Lusat.
Lusat and Azur were true masters at the academy,
after all.
They were dubbed grand masters, specifically,
with special robes that reflected that - and
it seems no one ever went on to achieve such
a rank, or sacrifice as much, as they did
[Source: Azur's Glintstone Robe].
And..they sacrificed a lot.
They can barely even move any more - and when
Sellen talks about them, she talks about them
being bodies, rather than a traditionally
living person.
Perhaps they've ascended to a higher plane
of existence.
Which would explain why they weren't really
around to form their own conspectus - something
that was left to Karolos, and Olivinus, and
others, instead.
---
With such enigmatic founders, many dedicated
themselves to the study of glintstone with
vows of virtue and austerity.
In return, they received the deep blue Robe
of Raya Lucaria [Source: Raya Lucaria], and
were able to study on its grounds.
Some nobles of Leyndell were even permitted
to study here - though their meagre accomplishments
never warranted them earning a stone crown.
To assist in their learning, a powerful spellcaster
would go and cast a spell called Terra Magica
from the tallest belfry of the academy.
Back then, this sigil was able to cover the
entire institution's grounds, and would be
cast with such strength, and allow for such
a vivid experience of spell-casting success,
that it turned "many a fledgling into a true
sorcerer in a flash of understanding" [Source:
Terra Magica]
But not all learning took place at the academy.
In fact, a couple of signature spells were
specifically given to those who departed from
the academy to embark on journeys.
Starlight is a spell that guides sorcerers
in dark places, and it reads "Even during
the blackest nights, sojourns underground,
or imprisonment in gaol, the stars are never
far from a sorcerer's side."
And then there was Glintstone Arc, which would
allow sorcerers to cleave through the ranks
of the fools that would outnumber them, on
their journeys.
Such journeys were encouraged by the academy
- there was even a conspectus for this practice,
called the Hierodas Conspectus, with a crown
that was granted to scholars who engaged in
nomadic study away from the academy [Source:
Hierodotas Glintstone Crown].
In-game, this crown is worn by Errant Sorcerer
Wilhelm, who fights with night sorceries,
and wields the staff of loss, which enhances
night sorceries.
This staff doesn't even have a glintstone
embedded in its tip, and supposedly can only
cast night sorceries as a result [Source:
Incorrect Staff of Loss Description].
That's how important asceticism was to some
sorcerers, and they believed that it was a
powerful path towards discovery.
This conspectus also seemed to see value in
depriving the senses.
The Crown of Hierodas is blindfolded, after
all.
We see this same practice of veiling the eyes
down in the Eternal City as well, and the
Nox's descendants were of course accomplished
practitioners of night sorceries, which seem
to be thematically tied to this blindfolded,
ascetic embrace of the void.
This habit of sending fledgling sorcerers
away must have posed a bit of a problem, however,
[See: Thops], as when war broke out in the
Lands Between, Raya Lucaria would close and
seal its gates, preventing access to all [Source:
Battlemage Robe].
Including its journeying, fledgling sorcerers.
The only way to get back inside, was to use
a glintstone key to activate the warp magic
within the seals.
These keys only seem to belong to accomplished
sorcerers - and they remember their users,
meaning thieves, or bluntstones like Thops,
could not get inside.
In the current age, Thops mentions that the
Academy closed its gates after declaring that
"they wouldn't interfere with the Shattering".
Now, this suggests to me that the Academy
had a habit of striving for a sort of neutrality
or indifference in world affairs.
Indeed, they had developed an entire Conspectus
who sought power in order to quell conflict
[Source: Haima Glintstone Crown].
These were the Battlemages of the Haima Conspectus,
who wielded stone clubs, and spells of cannon
and gavel.
A "gavel" is commonly used as a symbol of
judgement, and rather than interfering with
outside affairs, I believe the Haima Conspectus
mainly functioned as the academy's judiciary.
Their crown is even blindfolded, which is
widely regarded in the real world as a symbol
of unbiased justice.
[Source: Lady of Justice Statue].
With their preparedness for combat, the Haima
Conspectus were cited as being "the only ones
who dared to venture outside whenever war
had broken out".
And just like the blindfolded members of the
Hierodas Conspectus, the Battlemages of Haima
believed that seclusion was "no way to foster
discovery", and instead believed that it was
"only a convenient form of escape" [Source:
Battlemage Robe].
That said, we do find sorcerers of other conspectus'
outside the Academy as well.
Though you can sort of infer that they're
a bit wary to be away from home..because they're
often accompanied by Marionettes.
The Marionettes are dolls - constructs that
were crafted and animated by the sorcerers,
who are their masters.
There are a couple of variants - an avian
variant with curved swords that can fly and
throw fire pots, and the typical marionettes
with spiked spears, short swords, and shortbows.
Lots of shortbows.
These will commonly drop down upon you in
ambush, and while they like to go a bit ballistic,
they do act as crudely effective support for
a ton of the sorcerers that you'll meet in-game.
You'll even find a few of these down in the
Raya Lucaria Crystal Tunnel, where glintstone
miners are hard at work extracting glintstone,
and ore.
These miners don't use conventional tools
though - instead, they mine with a Digger's
Staff, embedded with a glintstone, casting
spells such as "Shatter Earth" or "Rock Blaster".
A fascinating little detail here though, is
that these mining spells carried enormous
stigma at the academy [Source: Shatter Earth],
because they marked their user as a failed
scholar..perhaps as someone who had to turn
to menial labour - lacking the intelligence
to pursue the complex mysteries of the cosmos.
Indeed, the overseers attack by crushing scraps
of glintstone, rather than with any advanced
sorceries.
At the end of the Crystal Tunnel is a Crystalian,
an inorganic being that was hewn from crystal
long ago [Source: Crystalian Spirit Ashes].
But these are more than mere constructs.
They are ancient, and even possess a faint
sort of intellect dubbed the "wisdom of the
stone".
Long ago, they even made a "concord", or agreement,
with the Carian Royal Family.
We don't know the nature of this agreement,
but some can be found chilling upon the moonlight
altar, and we know that they did teach the
Carians a spell called Magic Downpour, to
mark the occassion.
And Raya Lucaria sought kinship with these
beings as well.
For they are "close to the ideals of the primeval
current, and so are revered guests of the
sorcerers" [Source: Shattering Crystal].
The best example of this might be down in
the dimly lit Academy Crystal Cave underneath
Raya Lucaria - a crystal cave that is not
mined - perhaps out of respect for the Crystalian
Duo at the end.
There are even living quarters down here - and
I suspect these belong to a group of sorcerers
called the "Crystal Cadre", which was founded
to research the wisdom of stone possessed
by the Crystalian.
However, just like the primeval current, the
sorcerers clearly don't have all the answers
on these beings.
They call them "inscrutiable", and note that
they have "but one clear purpose; and that
is to safeguard their crystals unto the end".
Though there is one theory on these beings
- and it's that they are waiting - yearning
"for the return of their creator who will
carve for them new brethren" [Source: Crystal
Weapons].
A few sorcerers down here researching the
Crystalian are in possession of the Twinsage
Helm, which marks them as members of the Twinsage
Conspectus.
These were the elites of the academy, "permitted
to study and excel in sorceries of all kinds"
- and I assume it was these members who would
climb out of this cave, and cast the legendary
Terra Magica, that would cover the entire
academy's grounds.
But the Twinsage helm wasn't the only mark
of a proficient scholar - there was also the
Witch's Glintstone Crown which was "granted
to a scholar who excelled in her studies,
which also merited the title of witch".
And again - you can see most of these Conspectus
portraits hanging in Raya Lucaria.
For example, here is The Witch.
The Twinsage.
Karolos, Olivinus..Lazuli?..all of these portraits
are hung in the Debate Parlor of the Academy,
where members would likely have engaged in
argument in order to test and help validate
their ideas.
It's also where I assume they argued whether
certain things even should be allowed to be
learned, or whether certain members should
be exiled.
But we'll get to that shortly.
The final conspectus we haven't yet mentioned
is the Lazuli Conspectus.
These sorcerers studied lunar sorceries - A
quote unquote "Heterodox pursuit that views
the moon as equal to the stars"..with a robe
coloured "in the hue of the full moon which
signifies their heresy".
And of course, these sorceries include many
signature spells of Caria [Note: You could
probably argue that the Lazuli conspectus
also showed up after Rennala was ousted from
Raya Lucaria].
This is Carian Manor, and to the south are
the stargazing rounds - both situated upon
the western coast of Liurnia - which, according
to the map, has always been closely associated
with Carian Royalty [Source: Map: Liurnia,
West].
They have been around for a long time.
A really long time.
Specifically, Caria traces its roots all the
way back to the ancient astrologers that existed
alongside the fire giants.
This is most apparent when looking at two
items - first the Sword of Night and Flame,
which became a "storied sword and treasure
of Caria Manor".
It was clearly crafted to commemorate the
astrologers early experiences with the primeval
current...and their shared experience with
the Fire Giants, as well.. and the fact that
Caria inherited this sword suggests that they
trace their ancestry back to the time of this
sword.
And then there's the Stargazer Heirloom, which
tells of the rise of Caria as a house of royalty
through Rennala, and herfull moon.
"The young astrologer gazed at the night sky
as she walked.
She had always chased the stars every step
of her journey.
Then she met the full moon — and, in time,
the astrologer became a queen".
This royal house continued this tradition
of stargazing, and raised princesses, and
Carian Knights to serve as their retainers.
One of the foremost Carian Knights was named
Loretta - a woman we talked about more in
the recent video on the Eternal Cities, as
it was rumoured that she was an albinauric.
Albinaurics, as you may know - were widely
despised in the Lands Between - though Caria
is one of the few factions that seems friendly
with them.
Albinauric sorcerers are found all throughout
Caria Manor, and one, named Pidia - is literally
called a "Carian Servant", linking the Eternal
Cities with Caria, in an alliance which perhaps
allowed them to learn more about the stars
[See: the Weathered Map that Pidia gives you.
It shows where to find Amber Starlight, used
to make Starlight Draughts.]
And Rennala, with her full moon sorceries,
was their champion.
A prominent one too , apparently [Source:
Remembrance of the Full Moon Queen].
And it's no surprise when you look at the
powerful characteristics of her full moon
- it has immense gravity, and eclipses all
other magics.
It lowers defenses.
It is "enchanting", and Rennala used all of
these traits, to charm the Academy [Source:
Remembrance], to "bewitch them", and become
not just the Queen of Caria - but also the
master of Raya Lucaria itself.
And so, of course, here is her portrait, displayed
most prominently in the Academy of Raya Lucaria...
---
Right next to what many assume, is a portrait
of Sellen.
For if you unmask her in-game..then she actually
looks very similar, to this witch.
[Source: Prizzaa Gaming Channel].
Someone who was worthy of an entire conspectus,
and apparently, was the most promising sorceress
in the history of the academy [Source: Thops].
But even Sellen, with all her promise, would
not be tolerated, in the end.
If you recall, I was exiled from the Academy
of Raya Lucaria.
It was for attempting to restore the primeval
current of glintstone sorcery.
The toothless pedantry peddled by the Carian
royal family can rot for all I care.
I want glintstone sorceries that open our
minds, unbound by terrestrial taboos.
No matter what we give in return.
For Sellen to know so much about what she
calls "toothless pedantry peddled by the Carian
Royal Family", I assume she was a part of
the academy during Rennala's reign over it
- and that it was Rennala's influence that
finally led to the Academy's intolerance of
primeval current research.
And Sellen wasn't the only one expelled from
the academy.
The masters Azur and Lusat - two of the founding
masters of glintstone sorcery, were at some
point driven from the academy, as well [Source:
Sellen's Dialogue].
And it's easy to see why.
The primeval current is dangerous.
Lusat's mind was broken after watching a star
cluster break apart.
Azur saw a darkness in the primeval current,
and was left fearful of its abyss.
Imagine something so dangerous that just looking
at it can damage your mind..
In this way the primeval current is almost
Lovecraftian in its horror - we can't pin
down the exact truth of why it terrifies,
but we see its terrible effects on others,
and are left to wonder.
What's more...this cosmic current is primeval.
It's one of the first, if not the first thing
to exist in the universe.
The fact that our cosmic origins might be
terrifying, really is a kind of bizarre and
bewitching thought, right?
But Raya Lucaria was an institution now, with
power, and influence in the Lands Between,
and with those things, naturally, would have
come a need for self-preservation.
And the biggest threat at this stage wouldn't
have been external..it would have been internal.
The biggest threat was probing the primeval
current too deeply.
And so, the masters Azur and Lusat were eventually
driven from the Academy, as was Sellen the
Witch.
When we first meet her, Sellen states that
glintstone sorcery is rooted in the study
of the stars, and that most sorcerers these
days have forgotten this fact.
She resents that the sorcerers took their
power, then turned a blind eye to deeper research
in order to protect themselves.
It's kind of easy to empathise with her, and
to see her as this underdog..fighting for
the truth against an enormous institution
-
But can you really blame Raya Lucaria for
taking a stand, when you see this?
This is a School of Graven Mages.
A mass of sorcerers, fused together so that
they might be fashioned into the seeds of
stars.
[Source: Graven-School/Mass Talisman].
As the lore goes, this was apparently a valid
line of research into the primeval current,
and that, in the name of that research, fellow
sorcerers should be "collected", and fused
together in a cluster.
These creations were considered "the nightmare
of the academy", representing Sellen's complete
loyalty to the truth, no matter the cost to
her fellow man.
Naturally, such a thing had to be forbidden..but
then, it's ironic isn't it?
That the exactly line of enquiry that gave
rise to the academy, was the very thing that
posed a threat to
its existence, in
the end?
---
And
it
was then, that those at the academy realized.
That Rennala was no champion, after all.
[Source: Queen's Set].
When we see her, we realise that she was likely
left quite witless and inate after this event,
and so it was no surprise that the Academy
took this chance to rebel against the Carian
Royals [Source: Miriel's Dialogue].
---
With Rennala essentially held hostage and
safely locked in their Grand Library, the
academy went to war with Caria - focusing
their assault upon Caria Manor, for that is
where a siege, commemorated by this graveyard
of swords, took place.
The enchanted soldiers who fought on behalf
of the Academy were named the Knights of the
Cuckoo.
Wearing red and blue surcoats that depict
their namesake, and carrying shields that
boasted high magic damage negation - they
were explicitly purposed as "mage hunters",
and have been quoted as stating "our enemy
is none other than Caria itself" [Source:
Cuckoo Greatshield].
They also throw Albinauric Pots, which reference
their torture [Note: The Albinauric Pot features
a Black Dumpling - a torturous headpiece]
and hatred of the albinaurics, who, again,
are found all throughout Caria.
But despite some of their descriptions saying
that the Cuckoo Knights were "sworn to the
academy" [Source: Cuckoo Greatshield], I think
that's actually just wishful thinking by Raya
Lucaria.
The Scholar's Armament/Shield spells, for
example, were actually spells that were, quote
unquote, "taught to the Knights of the Cuckoo
as payment for their contract".
So..they were getting paid to fight.
And learning these low-intellect spells suited
them, because they were NOT proficient sorcerers
- for example, instead of casting spells,
they would crush broken clumps of glintstone,
dubbed "faux sorceries", or fake sorceries,
by the academy.
But perhaps most telling about their loyalty
is the Cuckoo Knight Armor, which says "Its
left breast is emblazoned with a peering cuckoo,
whence came their name", straight up admits
that "perhaps the bird's shrewd gaze is an
expression of their refusal to be mere servants
of the Academy".
Anyway, whatever the case, the Knights of
the Cuckoo failed pretty hard.
They were not only defeated in the siege of
Caria manor - but they were turned into puppets
there, and many now fight on Caria's behalf.
We get an idea of how much they must resent
this - when they somehow break free and confront
Pidia - a Carian, an albinauric, and a mage.
Three things that they absolutely hate.